bostonimix has really been focused on
research and development so I think
their goals of what they really want to
accomplish are very different at a high
level than what we want to do I think
they really want to push the
Technologies the places that are almost
as good or better than what humans can
do that's kind of like the inverse of
what we want to do it's like almost
we're at the complete opposite end we
want to do nothing better than what like
a non-expert human can do so we look at
like the distribution of what every
human can do in terms of like what they
do every single day we want to just do
the blocking tackling work that a most
normal human can in the world
all right guys what's up I've got Brett
here with me Brett I thought a great
place to start this conversation was
around ambition uh you spent a good
portion of your career working in the
technology and software industry uh
there's a lot of people who are building
all kinds of cool software but it just
might not really be that inspiring to
the average person who's looking at it
from the outside now all of a sudden you
start working on this like Advanced
Hardware and people start saying wow
look at what this guy's doing he's got
all sorts of vehicles he's got uh
robotics like this guy is really going
for it what changed in your career and
like why kind of switch from what many
people from the outside would say like
cool but maybe not the most ambitious
thing to now going after what many
people would consider the tip of the
Spear of innovation and ambition yeah
well first thanks for having me on today
um yeah I can maybe give you a quick
insight into just my career in general
and maybe how I got here maybe it's
helpful roadmap for other folks so I've
done about 20 years now in building
technology companies uh a little over a
decade maybe like 15 years or so in
software and internet the last like six
or so years have been in areas of
Advanced Hardware and AI
um I think listen there's a lot to
unpack with that uh with that with that
question I think
you know fundamentally I think software
basically gave me the personal balance
sheet to chase some of these harder more
moonshot or deep Tech ideas that I feel
like as an entrepreneur it's like we're
on this journey to kind of solve these
harder problems to make the world better
that you know frankly it was just a
really privilege for me to be able to
try to work on some of these harder
problems last like five or six years
um yeah so my Journey's basically been
this you know like a marathon so uh you
know probably built now over a dozen
companies and uh yeah for the last like
six or seven years I've been trying to
swing pretty hard at some of these
harder problems in in areas of the
hardware and AI
and why is that the focus you mentioned
the personal balance sheet maybe you
could explain a little bit in terms of
you know was there a certain number you
had in your mind was there a threshold
was it something like hey I could live
for 10 years and not have to pay bills
or worry about that stuff like what was
the thing that kind of unlocked mentally
where you felt safe enough I guess to
really go for the most ambitious thing
you could think of
I think fundamentally like there's not a
lot of investors funding the stuff I've
been working on
um so you look at the early days of like
SpaceX and Tesla and Arabian like
they're not the Venture investors are
not in there and so um so you really
don't have a lot of private Equity or
hedge funds or family offices or even
sovereigns coming in very early so it
takes a really special
um you know it takes a really special
type of financing to get into this space
uh and for me
um you know after selling battery in
2017 I I basically fully funded Archer
for the first first year or so first two
years and um same here a figure for the
last you know first year so I just
personally uh funded the business uh so
I think
um you know yeah I think
I think it's a really tough space and
um I think it takes a certain type of
you know conviction at the personal
level to be able to fund these type of
things that I think traditional
Adventure is generally shied away from
the last 10 or 15 years and when you
start thinking about let's go with uh
Archer first right like why pick that
Advanced Hardware right and maybe you
can just describe a little bit about the
business but there's so many different
things you could work on obviously
things you know space and various other
uh kind of ideas that people have really
clinged on to but you went after
something that maybe people thought you
know was more sci-fi and not like
actually gonna happen uh and you've been
able to not only build the business but
eventually take it public as well yeah
so I started arching 2018
um it was a really rigorous process I
went through to figure out like what I
wanted to work on and what I wanted to
spend my time at
um you know ultimately went through uh
you know It ultimately came down to the
fact that I really wanted to help solve
traffic problems which
nobody's really worked on for like 100
years we haven't had any really Advanced
uh you know Technologies really helped
solve traffic and you know I think about
half the world today lives in cities and
I sit in traffic all day long it's just
it's just terrible uh I think second
um we're having this secular Tailwind
where basically all forms of
transportation besides Rockets will move
to Electric the century and um so when I
yeah from the early days of Archer there
was this idea of okay if we can start
moving a lot of this traffic that's on
the ground into the 3D airspace there's
you know
there's like several orders of magnitude
more traffic you can put in air uh we
theoretically make a lot safer we can
make a lot you know quicker for folks to
get around we can make it affordable and
I latched onto this idea that you know
this really hasn't been solved it could
be truly groundbreaking if I could go
out and solve it and um it's you know
last five years has just been this
incredible journey
um I yeah I basically
you know started out just by going I
basically like went back to school and
taught myself how to build these
aircraft and basically built them you
know this first several Generations by
myself uh with a small team and um
yeah it was just a it was it's it's one
it's been a great experience overall and
I think this business can
you know over time I think a lot like
Urban Air Mobility or electric aircraft
can be a really important part of the
transportation solution so let's dig
deeper into this because uh with archer
specifically there's vertical landing
and takeoff there's an electric vehicle
there's then what I'm just going to call
like air traffic control inside of urban
areas right there's a bunch of these
complexities that you kind of put all
together and for the average person
they're like that sounds like a
nightmare trying to solve all of that I
get the sense that you thought that's
why it was worth going after was if you
could solve all these problems and put
it together in a single solution there
was a lot of value to unlock there when
you started out how much of the
technology had already been kind of
created maybe in other areas and you
were more so aggregating and and putting
them together in a unique way versus you
all had to make you know very material
scientific breakthroughs and be able to
do some of the stuff for the first time
yeah I think there's when I started when
I started Archer there was
um a lot of the
fundamental breakthroughs needed to make
it happen or like the ingredients were
really solved I think um we're looking
at okay where do battery motor uh energy
and power density look like today
um you know aircraft controls for very
highly over actuated aircraft look
um you know we uh yeah what does the
airspace look like in terms of
management what does the real estate
look like to solve this what does the
certification look like to certify these
aircraft
and really what we were doing uh at
archer in the early days and it's
similar here what we're doing now
figures basically what I call Applied
research where there's been something
proven and demonstrated our breakthrough
um where we're basically taking that and
we're we're advancing it in a lot of
areas and we're basically
commercializing the technology and uh
you know back in 2018 when I started
Archer there were their electric
aircraft flying around it wasn't like a
a crazy thing to think of like electric
aircraft it could really work and um so
yeah so basically building on top of
that it was pretty clear that over time
we could basically stair step our way
into Market we could certify like
existing part 23 like airplane in the US
with the FAA we could use existing
helipads to take off and land from so we
didn't have to build like say new real
estate with like you know tens or
hundreds of millions of dollars
investment uh we could use a lot of the
traditional advancements that came from
like Automotive EV in terms of battery
and motor technology
um so from my perspective it looked like
relatively tractable like there's like
this really plan and I like for the
first year I was basically obsessed with
building like building out this like
basically like Excel spreadsheet I built
from scratch called it was basically
electric range equation it was like this
you know 100 lines of like all this math
that basically proved that this could
work
and I felt like I was running around
like a madman to like all these
investors saying like look at this math
like this is like fully fully works it's
here and like nobody wanted to hear it
for the first like three or three years
or so uh like nobody wanted to dive deep
into like the numbers and really
understand it everybody had this like
knee-jerk reaction like this is just too
hard or helicopters are unsafe
um or this is just not gonna work for
whatever reason like you know batteries
barely working cars they're not gonna
work in aircraft and so you had some of
these uh kind of like real really large
blind spots and a lot of the investment
community that
almost laid this like Arbitrage scenario
for for me to kind of go out and like
basically commercialize this technology
and make it happen and we're still like
in the you know pretty early Innings we
have demonstrated now
uh building out like six generation
aircraft we have a basically my uh the
aircraft that I've spent a lot of time
on midnight just came out into last year
which is a piloted four passenger
aircraft were actively certifying that
right now with the FAA
um and there's a chance we could be
first to Market here in the US which is
really exciting and when you start
thinking about the technology you
obviously have to interface with what
I'll call like the real world right so
this is the air traffic control the
cities those helicopter pads Etc how
much of uh the time did you spend early
on of like just make the aircraft work
and then we'll figure out the rest
versus it was more kind of system design
right you really had to think about all
of the different components that go into
this because that would actually be
reflected in certain technical decisions
you guys were making
yeah it's it certainly needs to be like
the latter we we really need to think
about like
um like axiomatically designing for like
the end State that's a really important
in Hardware uh if you don't really
understand exactly how the product needs
to look at the stadium used to enter
commercialization it means that you're
just guessing on what the product looks
like today and like almost 100 or 99 uh
sure you're gonna mess that up or you're
just gonna die you're just design it a
little bit differently you're going to
use a little bit different battery cells
that are maybe easier to procure I put
on the aircraft you're going to use
easier types of Motors or whatever
you're going to do and the aircraft's
going to basically be sub-optimology in
your Market there's going to be
something wrong with it that allows you
to read needing to redesign the aircraft
and Hardware when you have a redesign it
takes years to fix that so you really
have to look at the end State and say
what does that look like how does the
aircraft look what does the air traffic
control look like what does the real
estate look like what are the
certification requirements
um where are batteries at you know at
that point not like you know 10 years
from now but like at the point we
intermark it like you know what do
batteries look like things like that so
um and then you have to basically work
backwards and then as a startup like
clearly you can't go out and produce you
know like a full scale six thousand
pound aircraft like day one so the early
aircraft that I was building were 12
feet wingspan you know 100 pounds and
they were sub-scale demonstrators that
we were using to kind of just basically
validate that this could work and to
prove to ourselves we could build
electric aircraft and then incrementally
basically I was working on basically
bigger and closer to kind of in-state
Market aircraft and that was purely a
function of
how much capital and time it takes to
build large-scale aircraft to the scale
if it was if it was if we could have
built the full-scale aircraft A1 like I
would have certainly done it but those
aircraft cost you know tens of millions
of dollars we have a team now of over
400 people uh close to 500 like so that
just wasn't it was just intractable for
the first few years of the business talk
about financing of the business
obviously you were financing a lot of it
early on at what point did investors
become interested or were you begging
and borrowing and basically stealing as
much as you possibly could to get them
interested
um were they Venture capitalists were
they more kind of private investors what
was kind of your experience there and
trying to get something that's
considered Advanced Hardware funded
yeah when like my my early days of
Veterinary like I had a really hard time
raising Capital like I I feel like um
you know in 2012 I went into a couple
like investment meetings I think I was
meeting with Bane Ventures or a few
groups but I was wearing a full suit and
somebody told me like hey man you gotta
you gotta stop wearing a suit to all
these Tech meetings and um I just had a
really hard time like I just like nobody
really wanted to fund the business for
quite a long time even at veteran we
raised a little over 10 million dollars
so we just basically didn't spend a lot
we didn't raise a lot of capital
relative to some of the other groups in
the space and so when I exited veteri
I really didn't have an interest in you
know going straight into VC again uh I
really wanted to in some way control my
destiny be my own boss
and you know kind of risk the capital
that I had personally which I think is
an entrepreneur like is really important
is the entrepreneur willing to use their
own money
um to prove out their their right and
you know or are you gonna do another
packages like other people's money to do
that and I'm very squarely in the former
I feel like it's really important to
Pony up and basically make a big bet on
yourself
so yeah the first you know
year or two I just basically immediately
put a bunch of money in account and just
went heads down building products so
um you know one of the big inflection
points in the business early on is I was
actually at a I was at an electric
aircraft just like engineering design
course in Atlanta
and I think it was like you know late
2018 early 2019 and I met somebody there
a PhD student in aerodynamics and the
student really wanted to work electric
aircraft and uh that's it happened to go
to University of Florida where I went to
school and um invited me down to
basically meet the head of Aerospace and
mechanical engineering and ended up
basically building Archer out the next
two or three years at University of
Florida I basically built a full Lab
there I had a team of 12 phds and I
basically just spent like the first two
years down there like my what I had like
you know uh my older daughter every time
was like you know under one my wife were
living in this Airbnb in the middle of
Gainesville Florida you know coming from
Manhattan and my wife's like what are we
what are we doing down here and I was
like we just need to learn how to make
this happen we're gonna you know
spending like all my money making this
work I need to be basically a product
expert in the whole space and uh it was
it was just a great experience from
there the earliest investor I had was
Mark Laurie from from jet
um so I met mark work four or five years
ago in New York and
um you know at the time he was at
Walmart uh kind of post Jeff sale and
Mark was like the first investor to bet
on me
to really make this work so Mark put uh
you know pretty relatively sized check
into business relatively early uh so you
know yeah he was basically first outside
capital in uh from there we raised I
think about a 50 to 60 million dollar
series A
in 2020 and then basically a little
under a billion dollars the year after
and so when you start getting into those
bigger fundraising rounds what changed
like you went from wearing suits and not
being able to raise Capital to now all
of a sudden you're raising big dollars
right and kind of uh you're the person
everyone wants to come to you're the
person ever wants to bet on uh was it a
confidence thing was it just traction
kind of changes everything was there
something that you learned did you have
a mentor that told you hey you know
don't wear the suit go do something else
in the meetings what happened yeah
yeah
um
I think it wasn't really one thing I
think it was a Confluence of multiple
things that really helped I think one is
I had a track record of building
businesses and you know I think I think
I really felt sufficient uh and be able
to build businesses out like at the time
you know a few years into Archer I
basically built maybe a dozen companies
I really knew how to scale a team raise
Capital build great product ship into
Market grow it
um build build just overall good
business and um
so one is I had a great try I think I
had a decent track record at the time uh
two is we were we were in a really large
market so I mean if Urban Air Mobility
electric aircraft can work uh I think
there's some pretty substantial ability
to move a decent amount of traffic off
the ground into the air so think about
every trip you do to the airport that
might take an hour and a half we could
fly that in 10-15 minutes and uh it
should be really it should be uh
overtime really safe and affordable and
um so I think it was a huge Market
um I think a decent background for this
I was you know putting a decent amount
of money almost all my net worth in the
business so a lot of overall conviction
we had just a great team and we were
making great products I think like the
one thing I feel like over time I've
I've gotten better at as a CEO is
um you know I I basically am very
product engineering focused and we spent
a lot of time at Archer or I spent a lot
of time when I was at Archer building uh
focusing on just designing the best
aircraft possible that could basically
um ultimately build the best business
over time and if you look at the Archer
aircraft today it's just you know in
terms of payload speeds range
utilization it's probably one of the
best designed uh and engineered aircraft
in the whole market and um I think that
became pretty clear in 2020 2021 that
the team was probably the best team ever
built for electric aircraft
and then uh ultimately we had a product
that could be certified with FAA and got
it to Market and could do the real
missions and I think if you look at the
space a lot of people got that wrong and
I think they still are getting that
wrong if you look at like the basic
physics of like what you need and it's
the same for any business you're in
marketplaces or SAS like you need some
like characteristics that would
ultimately make it a good or bad
business and you know in Hardware it's
like what are the physics and ultimately
what can the product do into marketing
commercialization perspective I would
say maybe half of all the electric
aircraft businesses in the market have
aircraft that are just not sufficient
like on the back of the napkin
and um I think Archer really emerged as
this uh very sober realistic and
fast-paced startup that was highly
capitalized that could basically be
poised to
um maybe be one of the groups that like
can help really make this industry work
and if it works it's the trillion dollar
market could be great and I think that
really enabled us to raise a pretty
substantial amount of capital that
enabled us to get to where we are today
and they're just like listen there's
still a long road left sorry
um certified lights are shut off
um there's uh there's still there's
still uh there's still a long road left
we have to you know certify the market
certify the business we have to
manufacture at low volumes and higher
volumes we have to get into Market
manage the fleet of aircraft and move
people around like that's that stories
you have to be told and so the team's
working extremely hard on trying to get
there now public markets versus private
markets obviously everything you had
done before I think was in the private
market now all of a sudden Public Market
uh pros and cons and like what
ultimately drove you there was the need
for Capital was it just it's the right
time what happened yeah so
um you know we went public through this
back in 2021 there was a lot of
companies that did that and you know the
trade that I made at the time was we
could have either stayed private
um and knock on this back route and this
was like early right we were watching
all the electric vehicles and lidar
companies go public and I was just like
you know somewhat shocked on how much
Capital they were raising
at the time in like you know early you
know 2019 2020 if you're a hardware
company in the Deep Hardware space there
was really no Venture market for you
kind of after the seed round and I I did
the seed round like so like after that
it wasn't like um the top DCS were
coming in and you know doing the series
a rivian or Tesla and space that wasn't
happening so at best the kind of post
series a and I I raised a you know
pretty traditional Venture series A
there wasn't really you know if we were
going to raise 100 200 300 million there
wasn't really a market for that there
was at the very late stage if we were
like you know making revenues and gross
margin but and then maybe the very early
stage when somebody could come in and
take a decent amount of equity and write
like a smaller check but like in that
middle period there was just basically
no man's land so it's either going out
and raising like maybe 100 200 million
at whatever valuation or it was like go
public and raise a billion and I think
you know
that was the trade right we were a
little bit we were early pre-revenue we
were young business being in the public
markets and you know being a grown-up as
fast as we could or stay private you
know and at the time maybe raise like
very little money
so the trade was okay this business
needs a lot of capital maybe a half a
billion billion dollars to get into
Market
um let's let's let's optimize for
Capital let's use that Capital to go out
and build uh this business out and get
into market and we basically chose to do
that and
um we raised a substantial amount of
capital like a little under a billion
dollars we closed into 2021 from that
process and that's being used to fund
the development and certification of the
aircraft
it's incredible
um you did it once you signed up to bang
your head against the wall uh and and
did it you know fairly well compared to
uh to many people who who kind of don't
build a successful business and then you
signed up to do it a second time now
with figure uh why do it again are you
addicted to it is it something where
you're like oh I've got this Playbook
now like what is driving you to do this
a second time with Advanced Hardware
I think what we're doing at figure
has the potential to be maybe like one
of the most groundbreaking businesses
I've ever seen
and um
I think there's a chance here to really
put robots into the physical world to
help with
just basically help with a wide variety
of problems we're facing here
um we have problems in the labor force
which we think we can really help we
have problems in the consumer side of
things at home caring for the elderly we
think we can really help address
we think over a long longer timeline in
the limit we can help with HEI
which will be really important
so I think
I think what's driving me here is I
think one is we can make a we can ship a
lot of product our humanoid robots into
market and make a substantial impact to
humanity and two is I think
I think this is going to be just a like
a really incredible business so I think
I have the saying that like I really
want to wake up to a future that's
exciting and inspiring I feel like
what's more exciting than you know
building robots to help the help of the
world and I think um so here at figure
we're designing uh autonomous humanoid
robots our thesis here is that almost
all the physical world was built for
humans so I have this analogy it's like
you know similar to the internet when
you go on the internet the universal
interface is a keyboard and mouse it's
how you interact with all the web
and even your phone you're like your
thumbs are basically like little
keyboards
um
so here in the physical world that
equivalent is the human form so the
whole world was built for the human form
to interact with whether it's like the
shelves in a warehouse that are five
feet high or the door I'm gonna leave
here or you know the tools I'm going to
grab and go use something with like
everything was made for the human body
it's like we have like a human operating
system in the physical world
so the play here is if you can build a
robot that can do what a human can you
can basically solve like millions of
problems in the world
um you can do all the jobs that are
dangerous and monotonous and boring that
humans don't want to do
and we think we think here that that's
possible and it could be
one of the more important businesses
ever built so
um I just feel lucky to be here with
probably the best humanoid robotics team
ever built we're about 50 people now
um we just brought up our full-scale
humanoid uh earlier this year and we
just did first steps of that humanoid
last month which
from our indication so it's we basically
did First Steps from under one year from
we started uh with the human nerd robot
which
you know from from what I know publicly
is probably the fastest humanoid project
ever built and so um I think we're
making substantial progress here and I
think over the next few years we really
hope to introduce this product into
market and to show it's actually
feasible and really working
um I think we get a lot of heat for
feeling like this is maybe too far out
there or maybe like 10 or 20 years into
the future that this will be possible
but we really believe over the next year
or two we can really demonstrate this
into real markets
um and I think that's you know I think
that's somewhat contrary right now in in
this space
so I want to dissect kind of the anatomy
of an ambitious BET right when you
decide that okay this is the project
that I want to go work on what was that
process like did you sit down you're
just like what's the biggest Market in
the world it's humans uh or did you do
something else like what is the process
to go from I've had my successful
companies now I want to go work on a new
problem how do I decide where to invest
my time energy and mental uh kind of uh
Focus
yeah so I basically go through a whole
Playbook exercise for this it's um you
know it's it's not a very quick one it's
very exhaustive like research or
database prop like process I run through
but at the very highest point I really
want to try to make as much impact as I
can and that's internally working on
Frontier Frontier technology areas I
think technology is the one of the
biggest lever arms to make as much
impact as possible in the world and so
um within the kind of Technology
umbrella I'm looking for areas that I
can move the needle and make as big of
an impact as I can
um and so I think for me it's impact
driven
um what do I want to like spend my time
on personally outside of that you know
do I am I excited or inspired to be
working on this X or Y project
it needs to be trackable in the sense
that like this can be doable and yeah
the business can can actually really
work and we can actually ship products
um it can't be too far out there where
we spend 10 years and just don't do
anything
um so I think you know can we raise
enough Capital Can you hire the team
what is the area of research and uh you
know uh what is area maturity of this
this industry in different Sub sub
components
um yeah so that process takes a lot of
time it's relatively exhaustive and I
want to really understand that
um whatever I work on is is something I
can actually really be successful at I
think
the last 10 years for me have been like
um dominated by this fear of spending
like 10 or 15 years of my life doing
something and just not working like I've
had you know like when I started veteran
we were in the NYU incubator there was
like it was like a little over 50
companies at the time
I think me and two other companies made
money like we're successful that's it
you know so maybe like that's a six
percent or so hit rate so 94 of folks
just didn't make it and they were all
like highly ambitious
really smart hard-working folks with
good ideas overall so this is a space
where you need to also survive and build
build a business and so
um when I looked at figure I looked at
okay I think this could could probably
be one of the more important businesses
potentially built by Generation
Um the the talent is pretty scarce there
was like a very small talent pool that
really understood like legged robotics
or humanoid robotics it was much smaller
than what I even saw an Archer much
smaller than what you would think when
you look at like traditional like
autonomous vehicles electric vehicles
um I had the personal balance sheet to
sell fund so like from a capital
perspective I would say a little bit
different equation there given like you
know the maturity of my career and the
technology side in terms of like
Advanced areas of locomotion
um batteries and Motors
um you know the autonomy and AI systems
for semantic behaviors and perception
like I I really
um did a lot of research understanding
what the state of the art there was and
I felt very convinced that this was the
right decade to make this happen and it
just seemed like this full court press
push like we had to basically build like
a greatest team of all time we would
need to work really hard
um we need to be really thoughtful about
what we spend our time on to make sure
we make actual progress because the this
Hardware space is
so damn tricky and so we really don't
have enough time to spend a year and
just kind of like going in the wrong
direction it's okay for like heading
north and we need to like pivot a little
bits like Northeast or Northwest but we
really can't be heading south for too
long or it's going to be oh we won't
make it we'll go bankrupt and so yeah I
basically spend a lot of my time making
sure we're going the right direction
what is the state of product in product
and Engineering which axiomatically for
me is the is the most important thing
like if you have a really good product
it's easy to raise it's easier to raise
Capital find the right Partners hire the
team ship products read like you know
have like a sticky product like increase
margins over time like axiomatically
everything sits with the product so
um so I felt like we could build a
really groundbreaking product here and
then on the back of all this we're like
the economy is seeing like substantial
uh declines in like the labor population
we just don't have anybody that wants to
do these jobs anymore so the
conventional wisdom is like we'll walk
in and we'll take people's jobs and
humanoids Robotics and it's just it's
just false we're walking into warehouses
or manufacturing facilities they're
seeing like 100 to 200 annual turnover
there's nobody that wants to do these
jobs anymore there's like I think
there's like 11 million jobs unfilled in
the US so we want to walk in and fill
that void which we think is a really
fundamentally important boy to fill in
the US and also worldwide
um yeah so like for I think um
for that reason I think I think this
could work uh on the back of all that
work and um you know I think I feel more
convicted every day I spend inside the
business here and inside the product
that
we'll have a real run at this to see
like to try to make this happen
when you think about how big this could
be right
um you start talking about uh these
autonomous humanoid robots that seems
like it's either the craziest idea in
the world and if it works it could be
unlimited trillions of dollars of value
created or that sounds like the most
insane stupid idea in the world and it
ends up being you know this whole
exercise and like everyone loses all
their money talk to me about the upside
the optimistic view of this right it
works
how big can it be or do we not even
understand that yet
I think there's like a couple like like
there's like near-term success and
there's like obviously the long long
term success I think at a very high
level from a macro perspective we're
sitting the largest economy on the
planet so
the economy for physical labor is half
of GDP so half of the world's money pays
for humans to do work
we have a flatlining labor population
meaning the people that were paying to
do the work is flatlining and starting
to decrease globally and that's a
demographic problem we have the baby
boomers are starting to retire we
haven't had as many kids it's leaving us
like the middle area of the economy
um and basically in shortfall and so we
have the ability to come in and
basically be a generalizable substitute
for human labor meaning we can put
robots in to do the things that humans
there's not enough humans today to do
and so so the from the from the tan
perspective it's quite it's like the
largest in the world it kind of it
dwarfs the transportation market like
globally I think Transportation markets
big it's probably like an order of
magnitude bigger than transportation
um we have this like on the you know on
the supply of people that's basically
like starting to Flatline and go down so
if we want growth we need some sort of
Automation and we feel like humanoids
can be a great uh basically product for
that and so in the near term call it
over the next like you know five to
seven years we feel we need to
demonstrate that this is actually
trackable and actually works meaning we
put humanoids into real labor
applications and it's actually doing
work that's useful and I think that's a
huge hill to climb we're trying to climb
that hill right now
I think if we're able to do that you
know comparatively if you look like
self-driving cars this is certainly a
bigger Market I feel and it's I think
it's going to be easier in the sense
that like the safety for self-driving
cars is a is a huge um dependency in the
road map for deploying Robo taxis at
scale
um and a lot of that stuff is
pre-revenue I mean waymo crews are 30
billion dollar companies
um so I think
I think there's a optimistic view I have
that if we're able to put humanoids into
real labor labor areas with real big
clients actually getting paid for that
and doing that over the next like two to
four years I think there's no reason
this business can't be worth more than
Cruise
in the next like five years and then I
think long term it's a matter of like
being able to really scale this out with
a real Fleet of robots at really high
reliability and high safety and um
there's a ton of challenges there we
have to manufacture really high volumes
and there's a very steep learning curve
for that we have to have like robot
reliability extremely high uh which is
hard like think about a million robots
all over the world and they need to be
like they need to be working almost all
the day without any human intervention
we can't really have robots like
stopping or dropping things and not
knowing what to do next like it's
impossible to have a human interface to
a million robots and going in and fixing
them one by one or tele operating in and
saying hey robot do this like we have to
have the robots work autonomously across
the whole mission
um but I feel you know if we're able to
the first hill we need to climb is like
we need to have robots into real
applications doing real work that's
useful and I think we're working on that
right now we want to try to demonstrate
that over the next year in our lab and
then within the next like kind of 24
months or 36 months we would like to
have
um early proof of concept of our
humanoids in real in real companies
doing actual work I think long term
there should be an ability to build
perhaps the world's largest business
here I think it's just it's just um
you know the math behind how large the
market is
um and I'm not saying that'll be a
figure but I think the humanoid space
will give like rise like some of the
biggest businesses on the planet
as you start going down this path I
immediately think okay who else is doing
this right and I think most people will
see Tesla and some of what they've
discussed and some of the mocks and
things like that they've put forward
um do you see them as competition do you
see them as no actually we need as many
people seeing the opportunity as
possible and kind of all boats rise
together are there other companies maybe
that you spend more time thinking about
than Tesla talk to me about you know
maybe the the market so far and how you
think it develops over the coming years
yeah this this looks a lot like pretty
similar to what I just went through at
Archer I think um there's been no
successful commercialized humanoid
robotics
um company in history
so in terms of like who's actually has
humanoids in Market generating revenues
it's there's zero globally so we kind of
view
like that's like the mid that's like the
minimally viable level that we need to
get to to show that the comp this could
be a real company
so as of right now there's there's just
no there's nobody in the planet that's
been able to do that
um you know I think we like at least
figure because I can speak for ourselves
I don't you know can't really speak for
Tesla and these other other groups I
think figure over the next like 24 to 36
months our goal is to try to show that
that's really possible
and um I think it's going to be very
hard for a lot of groups to get there
given how very little people on the
planet know how to do this it'll take a
decent amount of capital take a decent
amount of time the technology is just
extremely hard so it's not like it's
like okay just go get these things and
put it all together and make it work
it's just not like that we had to uh
basically build from scratch almost all
the software you know all the powertrain
um you know all the autonomy like all
that stuff and the controls like all
this stuff was just signed in-house uh
from scratch and it's just really
difficult to do it
um so yeah there is Tesla on the market
there's a few other groups that are kind
of uh doing this for more like a startup
perspective but I would say on the whole
it was probably very little competition
globally uh I hope uh more than one
group kind of figures this out uh that
it's probably not a winner take all
Market I would say it's probably winners
take most similar to autonomous vehicles
the space is just too big for one
company to win
um but I also think it's not like a
third companies are going to go figure
this out I think it's just too hard and
I think there's a real first mover
Advantage Advantage for a company
getting to Market
basically using the perception systems
and sensors to build an AI data engine
which then in turn is going to train the
robot on how to do new things so the
initial robots will be in Market as a
fleet Gathering data training the neural
Nets on how to train the robot to do new
applications that will then in turn
allow the robot to do two new things
that was never you know taught to do
initially and so that's going to be a
really important flywheel that we need
to start from day one that we're
starting on right now that will be
really hard to compete with if you have
a bunch of you know if a few companies
in Market that are generating that data
and you're a new up and comer five years
later
it'll be very difficult to compete in my
mind
one of the questions I was going to have
for you is are you a hardware company or
a software company at the end of the day
right it's kind of Tesla is at a car
companies as a software company what is
it maybe the labels or the
characterization of the business doesn't
actually matter at the end of the day
like the Market's just going to
determine the winner but how do you
think about uh where those modes are is
it in the data or do you think that
there's just really hard technical
problems with the hardware that if you
figured out other people will struggle
to do it so in the lemon I think figure
is going to be an AI business long term
so the reincorporated figure AI Inc it's
figure.ai
um
in the limit the autonomy and AI will
will ultimately Drive
like long-term success characteristics
of the business and
like on that way there's a bunch of
other things we have to get right uh and
not take for granted and the Hardware's
got to be great and inside the hardware
umbrella there's a lot of pieces here
there's you know actuators which can be
broken down into like
the motor and the sensors and
transmission so there's a lot of stuff
there there's like there's the rotor
stator transmission sensors enclosure
controls like there's a lot of like
there's a lot in that little umbrella
there uh the battery areas the joints
the kinematics we have to get the
Control software uh right we have to get
the middleware operating system right we
have to get all the electronics right so
at this point we're building all of our
Electronics from scratch
um so there's a lot of things we need to
do right and I think
even in this near-term window I think in
the robotic space
I think a lot of folks take like a lot
of companies last like couple decades
have really taken for granted how
important it is to design really great
Hardware
I think folks you know feel like okay
it's like you know we'll just buy some
some Motors and some robots off the
shelf and just design grade software
like to build a great robot the hardware
needs to be really great and the
hardware is just extremely tough there's
a lot of degrees of freedom there's a
lot of parts a lot of fire conditions uh
so we we try to build Hardware really
well here so we have a really large
Hardware team the team is just
absolutely fantastic we're working now
through our second generation robot
which will be done within the next like
several months and um I think we're
making some of the best improvements in
human or Robotics and the hardware side
I've ever seen but yeah I think getting
back to your position I think in the
limit we become a software AI business
and
um there's just a substantial amount of
work that we do in here to make the
humanoid useful at scale so one of the
things everyone is either worried about
or excited about when it comes to AI is
Agi and if you have a humanoid robot who
stands let's say on a um kind of
manufacturing line and you say you know
pick up the box put it on the conveyor
belt pick up the box put on the conveyor
belt people like oh that's amazing I can
see why that's valuable the second that
you say to the humanoid robot hey go
into this building and figure out how to
make me money people get a little uneasy
when there's even grander things that
aren't just like hey go to work
essentially and figure it out uh people
get even more uneasy how do you all
think about the pros and cons is Agi
inevitable in these humanoid robots and
like what are some of the things maybe
you haven't figured out what you're
thinking about today and and need to
figure out before we get there
there's there's really this debate
that's happening right now
like as it relates to AGI on
whether there's enough data online to
basically get to ATI is there enough you
know say high quality words that can be
trained in a large enough large language
model uh to get the real agency I think
it's roughly anywhere from seven to nine
trillion high quality words on the
internet
uh maybe we've adjusted close to a
trillion at this point and um you know
is that enough to really have the
semantic understanding of the world and
to get the AGI and
um if it is it's definitely the cleanest
and best path towards AGI or the fastest
path
um if we happen to find and I'm a bit
skeptical here that we're able to do it
but if we're able to to not get there uh
through through language then I think
the
highest predictable path to AGI is going
to be through humanoid robots
and um and so both on like the vision
language side
and so explain that a little bit more
Brett in terms of I think when you say
that a lot of people will say wait a
minute I would think that uh that would
be kind of the Last Frontier why do you
think that is really the path
it's probably the Last Frontier if we're
not able to get there through language
meaning if large language models are not
able to semantically really understand
the world the way maybe humans might
because we have a physical interaction
and embodiment
um Community robots are probably this
like Last Frontier to get to AGI it's
going to take much much longer than like
through language
but it's a much shorter path to HEI like
it's a like if if there is a path to HEI
that can't be done through language it's
definitely going to be done through
humanoid robots
it's just going to take like
an order of magnitude or longer timeline
to get there
and
so I think in the limit we should be
able to hear to make pretty substantial
progress on that front
um it's just going to be much harder
because we need a robot and body AI in
Market collecting data in the real world
and policy information and doing that
training on the physical embodiment
which is much harder to do than just
scraping the web and doing next word
prediction
a little bit about the war for talent
like as you're talking about this right
there's obviously language there's all
these kind of different things that
you're throwing out there and all I'm
thinking in my head is man those are
some of the hardest people to recruit to
get them to stay compensate them you
know do do all the things that we know
go into this war of talent
and it's just a supply demand imbalance
so how are you all thinking about that
and how are you guys uh seeing where
maybe you have an advantage in terms of
getting people to come work with you
yeah so
I think about three or four years ago
when I was scaling up Archer
the the the war for Talent on that side
of things and electric aircraft was
built really on the powertrain side like
batteries and motors and that was a time
when all the electric vehicles were
scaling up electrification in general
was like you know all the car oems were
pivoting to electric vehicles
it was just like one it was some of the
hardest Talent I've ever recruited
um and then you know you know fast
forward now three or four years here a
figure
um the talent for AI is like even more
extreme uh so we're you know today
really competing head on against
open AI Tesla Cruise these like these
Bay Area uh AI companies were really
trying to hire the same same exact
Talent so much in a lot of ways that
that is being recruited here
um and it's yeah it's arguably some of
the hardest Talent we're we're trying to
hire here at figure luckily
um we've had
a large amount of success last 12 months
building out our Ai and autonomy team
uh which today is like you know I think
we're like a little under 10 or so folks
and um the team is incredible I mean we
have folks from Crews and Google
deepmind
um that have worked on like very
sophisticated uh models and policies and
the whole team is trying to solve these
problems uh basically these learned like
we're basically using learned policies
in that group uh on the humanoid
um that'll ultimately be yeah in Mark in
Market trying to get smarter every
single day
um it's I would say really Fierce I mean
we're when we lose people we're losing
people because they're getting paid
several hundred million dollars in cash
seven figures and in stock options or
stock rsues
I would say it's one of the more
competitive areas I've ever seen in my
career for talent uh luckily we have
this really interesting area of embodied
AI that folks can come into I would say
it's a relatively
um
yeah I think it's a relatively important
area and it's a relatively hard area so
I think it really attracts a certain
type of person that wants to come in
here and basically run embodied AI or AI
that would run on actual Hardware
when you see the progress that you all
are making what is the inflection points
that are yet to come that you think that
you guys can make before you've got to
get into the public markets or like you
know kind of get into the billions of
dollars raised right are there certain
things that you all are driving towards
you said you just took the first steps
what's kind of the next couple of things
that you all look as those milestones
yeah I think there's like two things
that are on the roadmap right now that
we
um that we're working through I think
the first is
which is arguably the most important is
we need to show a humanoid
uh works really well in a useful con
scenario in our lab so in our lab here
we have a full testing area it's
relatively large it has a full like
warehouse and fulfillment studio built
into there and that like basically
mirrors what we're seeing in Market our
clients so we want like really high
transferability we want the robot to do
well in our warehouse the Fulfillment
area here in our lab and then we want
the robot then to go into our clients
and then we want the robot to do
extremely well there so that that
arguably the most important Hill that
we're climbing now in the Milestone is
like you walking in one day
and watching the humanoids do useful
work at human speeds like all day long
they're they're going out and doing the
work they're self-charging coming back
in they're doing the work again and
they're just doing that 24 7. and we're
minimizing the amount of human
interventions meaning like the
reliability is really high the human is
like not messing up throughout the day
it's safe uh so meaning like if humans
are walking around there's like um
there's there's a dynamic sense of the
robot of like not you know slowing down
as it approaches humans just overall
like basically adhering to the safety
system safety engineering requirements
that we have for the robot
um so I think that's like the most
important near-term goal that we have
and then in parallel we're starting to
um have very significant conversations
with our first uh potential clients and
what that would look like we're spinning
I would say two to five times a month
were on site at a facility somewhere in
the U.S whether it's a car OEM or a
large like retailer warehousing client
and we're like we're we're there for the
day just absorbing everything end to end
and how it all works and spending time
understanding their pain points what
requirements they need what performance
they need
um you know what is like their hiring
pains look like and labor attrition and
things like that and I think um those
two go hand in hand right like it's like
we we want to understand what the
clients really need we want to really
demonstrate that in a really useful
environment here in our lab and make it
like as real as possible and then at the
extent that works we want to put a
limited quantity amount of humanoids
into those first clients as a proof of
concept meaning there could be five or
ten humanoids at ex-client
um end of 2024 doing useful work and to
extend that's that's working well we
would basically scale up into that
application and then we would use our AI
data engine to basically teach the robot
how to do new things along the way
so as you're talking about kind of these
different things that you guys have to
do
how much Capital are you going to need
right like like is this a is this a
capital intensive thing where it's the
the talent is it something where as you
Mass produce the actual humanoids uh can
you get like lending facilities against
the hardware like like how do you think
about you know being able to efficiently
use Capital to be able to build this
business and are you going to have to
just do it with all equity and go raise
billions and billions of dollars you
know when you're at scale or are there
other things that maybe you guys are
thinking about in terms of how to
finance you know building out what
essentially is a fleet of you know these
humanoids
so I think so my view is that this
business
we have like probably the minimum
requirements we need a capital to
get into Market at low volumes and then
we have the scenario like if it works
how much capital is going to need
um starting with like if this works how
much capital is going to need
so to extend humanoid robotics
um are are useful we have them in the
clients it's working really well we can
manage the flee well everything's going
well
you'll probably be able to manufacture
more humanoids per year than cars
so we have like roughly 100 million cars
produced in the U in the world every
year
um I think there's an ability probably
to put close to 10 billion humanoids in
the planet the next like
two to four decades
so you would have like a huge ability to
manufacture
um a ton of capacity
um
that that business will need substantial
Capital you'll need Capital like a a new
electric vehicle startup uh you know
billions tens of billions that sort of
thing but that's basically in like high
growth scale you'd really understand the
economics well human rights would be
scaling the market that'd be a very
different type of environment that we're
in today
and then and then there's a question of
like okay we're like reversing back to
where we're at now it's like what is
really need to get in the market the
good news for like our business is we
don't have to have like
huge manufacturing scale to get to get
cost to a certain point where it's
economical for the consumer so like
electric vehicles basically have an
already Baseline like there's already
like this existing competition there's
already high volume
um like car oems that are manufactured
really high scale like you have to
compete against that if you're arubian
or Tesla or these new groups like
there's a certain you just can't like it
can't like be any price there's already
a baseline of what consumers will be
willing to pay and what they can afford
to pay that you really need to hit and
you need like really decent scale to get
costs down and so that's why you're
seeing substantial amount of capital
flowing in here in the robotic space we
could theoretically deploy 10 000 robots
in a market be unit economic positive or
cash flow positive and stop growing
and so I think here we need
you know in the Market at low volumes
probably low hundreds of millions of
dollars from here
uh we just announced last month a 70
million dollar series A
um we had just a great group of
investors in I also participated in the
round and that basically gives us the
nest capital for the next several years
so we're really at this point heads down
now just trying to get the robot to do
useful stuff why can we let's let's use
the capital to prove out a humanoid can
be commercially viable and if we can do
that then it basically I would say
unlocks
if we're able to demonstrate that
humanoid can actually be useful in a
commercial way I would say
it'll unlock this area of almost a
limited capital for the space
and space is just so large and nobody's
been able to get to this point I think
we're really trying to get to that point
over the next several years
talk about Boston Dynamics and like
they're you know people I think have
seen the videos where they're have human
esque things kind of doing flips or you
know jumping on top of stairs or
whatever the dogs maybe uh whether spot
Dynamics or others those seem to get you
know tons of virality
um
how much of this game is like uh
what there seems to be much more the
hardware and like kind of driving it
versus you all have a very specific you
know kind of idea of like we are
building a humanoid robot and so we're
making design decisions we're making
technology decisions specifically for
one use case maybe that's just my like
you know kind of stupid external view as
to they seem more like Let's Do Science
and Technology research and like we'll
apply to a bunch of things whereas you
all have this like laser focus is that
an advantage or maybe I'm even seeing
that wrong from the outside
I think your assessment is correct I
think Boston Dynamics is really their
Heritage of awesomenics has really been
in research and development and I think
they're they're humanoid program today
Atlas
um which is like hydraulic humanoid is
is in a research and development phase
and
um but I think Boston Dynamics have been
such an incredible job last like a
couple decades for robotics or robotic
space
um you know I just grew up watching
their videos and they've just done an
incredible amount of great engineering
work uh Mark raber the founder was
actually in her lab last week we had him
turn around showing him the robot
um he's such a great guy and uh we have
a we have a decent amount of folks and
Boston Dynamics here uh now figure that
that he knows really well
um but yeah I think your assessment's
correct boss Dynamics has really been
focused on research and development so I
think their goals of what they really
want to accomplish are very different at
a high level than what we want to do I
think they really and this is just me
speculating from from watching from afar
but I think they really want to push
the Technologies the places that are
almost as good or better than what
humans can do in terms of like you know
agility and Locomotion and speeds and
these different things
and that's kind of like the inverse of
what we want to do it's like almost the
complete opposite end we want to do
nothing better than what like a
non-expert human can do so we look at
like the distribution of whatever human
can do in terms of like
what they do every single day we
basically want to do
um
the most amount under the curve of what
a non-expert human can so that means we
we don't want to do box jumps and
backflips and super fast speeds it means
we want to you know we want to just do
the blocking tackling work that a most
normal human can in the world and I
would say that's pushed like at the very
high levels probably push
architecture decisions and the
technology in a very different place our
robot is fully electric or
electromechanical uh we don't yeah we
don't have the ability to do like 100
pound deadlifts and other things like
that nor do we want to
um so I would say
yeah at a whole you're yeah you're
probably right and
um but Boston Dynamics is just an
incredible organization and they
probably have some of the best
roboticists on the planet that are there
today and um yeah I'm super I think
we're super fortunate to have them in
the industry pushing us to where we're
at today and pushing us forward
I got two more questions for you and
then I'll let you go the first is
um the military has a robot called the
Talon robot
um and what always surprised me it's
something that's used to kind of go down
the road and look for IEDs and this is a
thing that is built for the most robust
you know kind of uh environments in the
world could literally get shot at Etc
but uh when I say it and people use this
thing it can also take an arm and it's
got kind of like a pincher uh type uh
device on it and it could uh with a
skilled operator pick up an m m without
crushing it and so this kind of you know
uh difference between like you got to be
robust enough to end up uh surviving and
thriving in a war zone but also have the
uh minute uh kind of uh ability to pick
up things with a delicacy to not crush
them always struck me as this like very
weird uh Illuminating challenge in
robotics what you all are doing seems
almost even you know more complicated
right you're talking about being able to
walk up without slowing down you're
talking about being able to pick up a
certain you know weight worth of things
but also probably have to do certain
things where you can't crush or break or
you know kind of violate how do you
balance that and how much of it is just
driven off at the understanding of what
a human can do versus you all are
looking at this as like we're designing
a machine we take some inspiration from
humans but it is a fundamentally
different thing in terms of you know the
capabilities of the machine
yeah so I think you're hitting on like a
really important point which is
to do everything a human can is
extremely complex like if you look at
like uh the easiest stuff a human can do
just moving boxes and the more dexterous
stuff
um more fine-tuned stuff you talked
about like you know putting a humanoids
in a home and cookie dinner
the the engineering challenges there
from like from start to finish are
substantial and in some way I equate
like this hardness scale similar to
self-driving where you have self-driving
cars that you know if you want to build
a self-driving car that drives on the
highway uh you know a decent a decent
safety standards reliability
burst like I say self-driving cars in
the city of San Francisco like the the
difficulty scale is probably like I
don't know maybe one or two orders of
magnitude difference meaning you can get
the market faster if you can just design
like a drive on the highway so my Tesla
drives flying on the highway the drive
into the city just creates all like a
lot of veritability less structured
environments just like very very
difficult from a safety perspective to
do that reliably I kind of think the
same thing for humanoids we have this
like scale of like easier stuff like
moving boxes and bins and fulfillment
that might be like say like highway
driving and then there's like no more
difficult stuff which is like put a
humanoid in a home to cookie dinner in
an unstructured environment every home's
different you're gonna basically have
different types of language prompts to
those humans like from humans to the
robots so uh our roadmap is designed so
we basically chew that off in some way
like almost serially where we can
intermarket uh use the data coming off
the robot to train the neural Nets to
basically get us from point A to point B
C D E and over time so
um I think that's the way that this
industry will unfold we'll unfold we'll
see humanoids in factories and
warehouses and Manufacturing
and then over time they'll be in more
dexterous areas of retail and other
environments and then you know like the
last chapters in the book are like uh
space travel cooking dinner in your home
caring for the elderly those type of
things once the cost is down safety's up
uh things like that so I think uh
yeah I think this it's extremely
difficult uh to answer your questions
directly and uh we're starting with more
tractable areas that we think are have
huge labor problems that we can actually
be successful and these spaces are also
enormous we can ship
tens of millions of robots into like
warehouses uh for instance
yeah it's fascinating to kind of think
about all of the the nuances here my
last question for you is uh kind of a
fun one
um but a little personal
what's your greatest fear in doing all
this like people see a Founder who has
continued to level up their game go for
something even more ambitious go for
something even bigger what are the
things that keep you awake at night or
what are the things that you're kind of
most fearful of I think the thing that
bothers me the most as an entrepreneur
is is spinning
a large amount of my time
on a problem or business that just
doesn't work
I think that's arguably the
least helpful I could be to the world is
I work on a problem for 10 years make
some small amount of progress but not
material and uh it just doesn't work and
I think that's
I think it's my biggest fear as an
entrepreneur and I think it's probably
every entrepreneur's biggest fear and
I've seen it just happen so many times
across just so many Industries and so
many friends
so
yeah and that can basically be like uh
you can kind of control that destiny you
can control the speed decision making
the speed of progress you're making who
you hire
uh how well those folks perform as a
culture and as a Direction as a CEO like
those are really things I feel like are
balls in our core to really to really do
I think at least for what I view I hear
a figure
and even Archer it's like the this is
all possible
it's ours to lose like we just got to go
out and get it done and um and if if
we're not able to get it done I'd be
like it'd be pretty upsetting because I
feel like
I feel like we have all the ingredients
down on the table to make that happen
like there should be no reason why we
I think there should be no reason why we
hit this wall that we're it's just not
possible to do
I um I'm cheering for you man I I think
this is super cool and uh I think
there's a lot of people who when they
hear what you guys are uh working on
um yeah there's kind of like why would
they do that and then once they
understand the Viewpoint the opportunity
and and how impactful this could be it's
hard to cheer against somebody who uh
who's taking the time and energy to it
to go build something like this so
um you've got a fan here and I think a
lot of people who watch and listen to
this will uh will also be fans where can
we send people to find either you online
or if they want to learn more about what
you guys are doing at figure
yeah so I would say
um definitely go to figure.ai it's our
website for the figure company I think
we
um we have like you know basically a
long-term Outlook that we wrote called
the master plan we have a culture
document we try to detail it as much as
possible uh please follow us on you know
Twitter will be posting a lot of
interesting Updates this year next so
we're gonna try to be a lot more
um we're going to try to be extremely
open in terms like building in public
and
um I think like this is such an
interesting space we really love we
would really like to set the business up
so people are cheering for us we don't
want people ruin against us so we really
want the world just hoping that we can
make this really work so uh yeah I would
say uh false false on Fall figure online
on Twitter and Linkedin and um I'm also
personally on Twitter I try to try to
address uh every week what's going on a
figure and uh I'm personally trying to
build in public more and uh I think it's
been really useful so far I mean we've
um we've had so much inbound demand for
talent in capital and partners and stuff
I think like we've had almost 20 big
corporates like I would say probably
you've had like almost 20 Fortune 500
companies come inbound in the last like
six months uh which has been great same
with investors same with you know uh
folks trying to apply so um yeah thanks
uh yeah thanks for having me on and uh
yeah hopefully uh have some more more to
share later in the year
autonomous humanoid robots for the win
my friend thank you so much for uh for
taking the time to do this and we'll
definitely do it again in the future
yep thanks for having me